he has been a revelation for the Saints
one of the top rookies in the National
Football League and perhaps most
importantly drafted by my fantasy team
in the one league that I really want to
win he's Alvin camara here on the red
show how are you Alan
that's last part you did not know that
piece of information I assumed until
just now
it didn't make it hasn't made around the
rounds in New Orleans is what you're
saying that hasn't made it back there
you know I'm sure you've why are you
walking the streets of New Orleans right
now Alvin I getting some breakfast you
know walk outside real quickly just
enjoy my little off day yes describe the
scene for me right now with you in the
Bayou where are you right now
Alvin yeah right now I'm down a magazine
over here by the ruby slippers just you
know grabbing some food okay do you have
a favorite breakfast spot there yeah
that's what it's called the ruby the
ruby slippers what do you get at the
Ruby slipper I get a cinnamon swirl
pancakes with with the candy bacon and
some scenery I just had a heart attack
during that Alvin my god well I mean if
I ate that I would have to work out like
90 straight days to work it off about I
guess that's what it's like young you
enjoying living down there I imagine in
New Orleans yeah yeah you probably won't
be able to run that 40 if you probably
my 10-yard split would that would suffer
that's for darn short and I know that so
how have you been able to adjust
seemingly so quickly to the National
Football League alland what do you what
do you attribute that to man just being
where I am in New Orleans I mean it's
such a welcoming place and I think just
with the organization it's also
welcoming and my teammates I mean
there's so many guys that are that are
looking to help me in any way that they
can I mean starting with Mark Ingram
just in the same room as me you know
open to any question anything that I
need anything I mean he's right there
you know helping me get better every day
and then to you know the rest of the
guys event guys from drew 210
again I mean Brandon Coleman Mike Thomas
Auto God
I mean defensive god Craig Robertson and
cam Jordan and Alex over for I mean
everybody I mean it's help and and
support coming from all inside I mean I
really have no choice but to be
successful what example can you give me
about Brees about how what he's put in
your mind's eye or whispered in your ear
at some point over the last several
months that's that's helped you I mean
with Drew is just it's not something
it's every week you know I mean he's
coming to me and you know whether it hey
listen let's work around after after
practice or you know uh you know just
keep what keep going we'll keep doing
this thing and and you know it's only
gonna get better from here I mean you're
just I've been saying it all season
Drew's just an open book
so I mean with with the things that I
have to do it within this office if I
have any questions or any any type of
confusing I mean I can go right to Drew
without any hesitation and ask him and
he and he clears it up with no doubt and
I you know I trust him with everything
Alvin Camaro Saints rookie running back
joining me here on the Rich Eisen show
you also had to go tin your your um or a
go in in your running back room for for
a little while and Adrian Peterson what
you learn from him man I learned a lot
to major you know just being the the
person that he is I mean first of all
he's a he's a great he's a great person
I mean and that's that's what I think
you know a lot of people don't don't see
that side you know they see the football
player but I mean he's an even better
man and I learned a lot I mean it's just
just life you know there's being a being
a man from him but of course on the
football side I mean he was pouring
everything into me that he knew he was
like man he's I wrote you you you were
built with rookies and I just want to
see you boss because I sort of feel
awful any questions I had I also felt
comfortable going to Adrienne - because
I mean he was just you know he's just a
bubbly person in then just soso opening
and welcome so it's it was great to have
him in there so and Sean Payton's
rolodex runs deep you know I know he was
the position coach or Marshall Faulk who
once sold popcorn in the Superdome he's
is new
as they come who has Sean Payton exposed
you two from football live football
history to try and get you prepped for
doing what you're doing right now I mean
they're like we haven't really gone too
far in the depth about you know the
football history with me but he I mean
of course they were with Strozzi that
was here and and Pierre and Reggie and
like you said here Marshall I mean just
some of the things that I've been doing
I mean he kind of goes back and says you
know this is how suppose used to doing
her this is how you know when when
Reggie did this this that you know so I
mean it I have all the information at my
fingertips you know I mean anything I
asked I asked sometimes we might have a
round not ask because paying like where
is that like you have a clip of this or
can I see this or what do you think
about it and I mean I also just with the
with the index and a film that we have I
mean I could just go back and pull up
any of those guys films and and see it
for myself it's remarkable how deep it
does go and paint and there are no six
and you know I did see a quote from Sean
Payton saying that the only thing
holding alvin kamara back from being
Rookie of the Year is me is what he said
what do you what did he mean by that do
you think Alvin yeah I guess I guess if
because paying top dollar dollar
you know dialing it up for me then I
guess I wouldn't win it but you know I
think he's been doing a great job of
just premium position I think that's one
of the biggest things you know coming
into the league I mean if you have a
coach that can put you in the right
position to be successful I mean it
makes all the difference well I mean I
guess part of that means is that he's
he's he's not throwing you out there for
20 30 40 touches how many touches a game
do you think you could handle in the NFL
right now Alvin yeah yeah yeah never put
a min or max on on what I can handle you
know I'll just say whatever whatever
thrown on my plate you know handle it
whether it's lower high in the middle I
mean it's whatever and you know
interestingly enough
what uh what a catch you had over the
weekend a cap a comeback that eventually
was the wind what was it like in the
huddle with breeze and those fights
Alvin we do I think I said it after the
game you know I got the same question
and withdrew it's like ultimate calmness
with him you know you're walking through
the huddle and he's just looks up at the
clock
he's like alright here we go he's like
alright we got time we got plenty of
time we got plenty of time and I'm like
that disbanded so pause like he got a
quarterback the thing I forgot it you
know I got a small job in this and he's
like he's so calm so I'm like I have no
reason to be to have any stress like
he's the commander so when he's when
he's hitting like that it makes it hard
to not be locked in and just focused and
ready to attack
and then you just I mean you double
caught that thing how often you practice
Alvin how often you practice there that
right there I'll just kind of tweak my
my eyes on the ball and luckily it
bounces and kicked in front of me and I
was like just focus I was looking at the
ball I was like man if I take a hit I'll
take you this whatever I caught it and
luckily they weren't trying to tackle me
and I got into the end zone I was - I
and you'll hit the sewer and then you
jumped into the stands with the fence
yeah before the game I was like hey if I
score I'm getting into the light I'm not
just leaping on the on the mulberry I'm
getting in the stands with the fans but
did you do you call that a floor dilip
did you coin that I saw somebody tweet
it to me and I love him that's cool yeah
that's what it is just leap I love that
that is fantastic
so who's talking Super Bowl around there
Alvin walk me through it man look I say
I stay away from that I'm just I'm
saying that I'm staying
tunnel vision on the goals that we have
we got another game this week so we just
got to stay focused on what we need to
do you know and that's win a game he's
we all want to know every week mm-hmm
and where and and where does let's be
honest here where does
all that goals of you personally
professionally where does making sure my
fantasy team wins at all rank Alvin
seriously be honest with me here I mean
that matter I know your fantasy you know
your fantasy plots and plans I guess
it'll be up there in the top five also
you can look you know Alvin I appreciate
that I understand you've got teammates I
understand breeze might look at your
sideways if you put it any higher than
that I appreciate that but there's a lot
on the line there's a lot I dragon I
drafted you I dress cuz I saw you at the
combine Alvin I saw you at the combine
Charles Davis who's mister Tennessee's
been whispering in my ear about you for
a very very long time and then you know
and then and Peyton clearly saw
something in you what was what was that
draft experience like for you sit in
their third round get the call from
Peyton Manning of course it was it was a
lot of talking about me in the first
round thing around it and honestly the
whole through the whole process I was
like man I did what I had to do yeah you
know now it's just the waiting game you
know I wasn't thinking about okay well I
should go first or us to go sick and I
was like wherever I land you know I'm
gonna be grateful for where I am and I'm
gonna go to work so getting that car
from coach painting I mean it was just
like it was a blessing you know it was
it was definitely I think everything
happened for a reason and it stick out
the way it stuck out for a reason and I
think I'm where I'm supposed to be Alvin
look I really appreciate the call good
luck to you the rest of the way good
luck to us I'll be very honest you the
rest of the way okay you got very good
and enjoy that breakfast at the at the
Ruby slipper there in okay very good
there's Alvin Kamara Saints rookie
running back the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience